I'm currently doing a month of focus naturopathic cancer therapies, five days a week, nine to four such as IV vitamin C with ozone, there you go again.
H bot in parensanas beamer, which is PEMF, that's a low gauze PEMF knife and attempting to get more consistent into ketosis while taking supplements and weekend coffee animals.
After having a full body MRI in January, I'm sensing it's time to get a PET scan when I return to the cities in order to see what is active versus dormant.
So first of all, I want to make comment about doing this and doing all these things. These are great. At least can really help with detoxification pathways and all that kind of stuff.
After doing a full body MRI in January, it's going to get a PET scan and return to the cities in order to see what is active versus dormant.
I had intended to get one back in December, but decided against it, however, of a full.
Have a bottle of supple, but you recommended to help get rid of the radioactive stuff that you're talking about.
Someone else suggested getting chelation IV immediately following a PET scan, any thoughts or on the chelation IV.
So chelation IV, where I think that is beneficial is if you have acute heavy metal toxicity, like you're exposed to arsenic or a little bit of mercury.
Chelation IV has a lot of downsides. So you're putting a heavy key later right into your blood vessels to pull stuff out of the tissue.
Right away, you have to your your bells and whistles should go off because you are going to be pulling stuff out of the tissue way faster than your liver phase one phase two phase three pathways are going to be able to get rid of it.
And all you're going to do is circulate around your body now in a crisis mode where this person has been exposed to a high amount of heavy metals and they're poisoned. That's where you just got to do it.
But in a situation like this, no, I would not say doing, you know, radiation, the amount of radiation that's in a PET scan is not worth IV chelation therapy. You could make yourself a lot sicker by doing that.
So chelation IV has a lot of downsides.